and memorial day is right around the
corner and people all around las vegas
are really celebrating the holiday
weekend
some events more somber of course than
others madison kimbrough joins us live
tonight from the historic woodlawn
cemetery where a special ceremony is
planned for monday
madison hey sasha yes take a look as
you're going to see
hundreds of flags here on the
gravestones of
american vets on monday the annual
memorial day service is planned for
right here starting at 9
30 a.m the state leaders will be there
to honor these deceased veterans
and it is open to the public another
popular event
is at the veterans memorial cemetery in
boulder city
staff spent the morning placing flags on
every grave
on sunday morning a local vets
motorcycle club will be there
to ride from arizona over the hoover dam
and pass the veterans home
this will be the 27th year they've done
it and a short ceremony is then
planned for monday that's going to be
around one o'clock
back out here live at the historic
woodlawn cemetery
the ceremony again honoring these vets
will take place at 9
30 in the morning on monday and then it
is set to end at 10
15. reporting live madison kimbrough 8
news now